well i went to see dark knight rises and
uh it was great i thought it was really
fun but i thought that it wasn't as good
as dark knight and uh that put me in
mind of a thing that nerds sometimes
think of as the rule of two right that
the second movie in any trilogy or
series is often the best movie you can
think of examples yourself but impressed
strikes back superman 2 spider-man 2
x-men 2. i'm gonna say even two towers
send letters if you disagree
you know the list goes on not temple of
doom
i know right
but that got me thinking about why that
is the case right why is the second
movie better and the easy answer is um
because you don't have to do all that
nonsense about origins at the beginning
right and that
is what has led me to a recommendation i
would like to make to hollywood which is
only make the second movie
don't make first movies anymore don't
make third movies anymore just keep
making the second movie over and over
again you know who's really good at this
james bond movies right i know that they
sort of rebooted with daniel craig they
kind of reboot with every new bond but
essentially every bond movie since the
second one for martial with love the
best bond movie
send letters
has been a second movie right
comic books are really great at this too
of course they're always sort of the
second episode every arc is the second
episode stanley and jack kirby figure
this out in the 60s that that's where
the fun is right you sort of have the
illusion of movement forward without any
real movement
it's the kind of thing that makes me a
little nervous about uh man of steel
coming up the zack snyder superman movie
in fact because when i hear that two big
movie stars are playing jor-el and
jonathan kent superman's real father on
krypton and his adoptive father on earth
i think oh god we're gonna have superman
with daddy issues right and that's not
what i want i want to see superman being
super right i mean what was the best
scene in in the last superman reboot
right it was the rescuing the airplane
right that was awesome the rest of the
movie
you know that's awesome right
and i think i figured out why this is
in a superhero movie in an action movie
the hero
is actually the antagonist from a story
structure perspective
here's what i mean the protagonist if
you go by um like the mckee school of
storytelling is the person who has the
goal is the person who's trying to
achieve something with constant
obstacles with opposing forces always
undoing that person's efforts and so
they keep having to make more and more
outlandish decisions more and more um
they keep having to do more and more
crazy stuff to get to their goal until
finally they're presented with so many
obstacles that are so hard to overcome
that they have to make an irrevocable
choice that's character defined and that
irrevocable choice when they actually
put that in action is the climax of the
movie if you think about it that's what
the bad guys do in these movies right i
mean that's what the bond villain does
that's what lex luthor does keeps trying
to do some kind of evil machiavellian
plan and who's opposing who's the
opposing force the antagonist it's
superman right
our heroes are the antagonists here but
i think that hollywood makes a mistake i
think that what hollywood does is thinks
that the hero has to follow the classic
joseph campbell hero's journey right has
to have an origin that also defines the
final climactic battle you know the
joker has to kill batman's parents
batman has to create the joker green
goblin is the one who runs the lab that
creates spider-man that kind of stuff
you don't have to do that anymore
i absolve you of that responsibility
i just want number two every time
i'm excited by this because i have a
feeling
that my new favorite movie in a couple
years
prometheus too